[Music]
have any of you guys
ever created some sort of like
presentation to get your point across to
your parents
like a like a like a powerpoint yeah
like a powerpoint white people [ __ ]
what did you just say that's some white
people [ __ ] yeah because if i did that
i'd get my ass beat facts it's like i'll
be like
uh i have a meeting i want to show you
guys if i bust out the projector and as
soon as that first slide goes up
that hat is gonna swing that is never
even an option
like present your case your case is no
what case it's a listen
i agree with you guys i've never done
this either and
i don't even think i was smart enough to
be honest that's true i mean i feel like
if i ever did a presentation it's
because i was told to
exactly like they told me it's work
that's the only time i ever read a book
too
like i never found reading fun what are
you going to try to present to them
right like what are our options here
like
why i should smoke weed in the house
i mean i don't know how old you are by
doing you know didn't know that was an
option then i didn't even know that was
available to us
i i i'm done with the stars now that's
weed
now it's really what would you do if
your son was like
dad i'm not gonna do the dishes and here
are the five reasons why what would
how would you feel i get a dish and
crack it over the head boy would like
that [ __ ] though
would you or if you were like i told you
go clean up the
like clean up the kitchen this is done
the other and then he was like well
dad but here's why we're gonna say eight
oh is he eight we're gonna say eight
cause i'm gonna say not not to where
you're impressed by it like oh wow
you're super smart but you're like
little [ __ ] yeah like what do
you want i think i think it depends on
what i think he needs work on and what
he is lacking
okay so if i see extreme work ethic
uh in other areas of his life then i'm
like let me hear
i'm like okay obviously he doesn't need
to do dishes because he already has
discipline
what is your plan and i want to see if
he's smart and been able to present it
so you're gonna hear that if yeah i'll
hear it out but if he's a lazy [ __ ]
right then i'm just gonna smack him
immediately because you know he's trying
to forget because he's trying to get
over it
i gotta see his whole picture right and
then see
hmm so there's a lot of factors into
this you know how bad that would suck
you spent
hours after they already told you to do
the dishes yeah you could have done it
and then you did this presentation and
they still say no
because you're going to learn first off
work smarter not harder stupid
could have just did the damn dishes that
would have been overpaid your brother
now that's a whole that yeah thinking
outside the box right
i mean it's always a presentation thing
too but anyway so there's this uh
story here from twitter so this guy
named christopher
doyle of course he did a presentation
well he tweeted out about his daughter
making a powerpoint a presentation of
course his daughter would make a
presentation if it's a daughter
i'm down yeah because it's cute or huh
it's so cute
okay i need to hear this whole story
i'll beat my son but never my daughter
was it why i should have a
boyfriend was it why i should have a
boyfriend no okay so let's let's yeah
what else do you guys think it was
uh i should have a boyfriend
okay we have no idea but the father's
name is what christopher doyle
why i should get a raise for my
allowance
why the maid needs to come back and
clean my room oh
why i should be allowed to wear makeup a
makeup that will wipe the bar in your
head
i already know the story so why i should
have a cell phone
oh well that's what isaac should have
done
begging you know how sometimes white
people take the draw off the
the white the door off the hands i was
like no that's a whole brown people
thing too
don't shut the door no closing the door
oh my god that's true that's a role in
our house too i just got i just got
flashbacks my dad used to make me sit
next to him
because he said going to your room is a
privilege i was like holy [ __ ]
he's smart my dad used to make us sit
next to him when we were in trouble and
if when my sister and i would fight
they'd make us hold hands
that's cool my sister and i would fight
they would hold him they would make us
there's you just oh yeah they used to
make us whole
hold hands have you seen that photo of
the t-shirt that some
white people made a t-shirt like why you
guys keep saying it like that no because
it was like these white people just say
some people
no because it was oh look at you 20 20.
i'm trying to be nicely 20 20 trying to
defend white people
my name's already because i
no but they really were i'm not trying
to say anything no but they really
weren't so then they had like this shirt
where they put like
two kids in one shirt because they were
fighting yeah my dad made us my dad made
us hold hands and then when we were in
trouble
he said that's a privilege for you to
get to go into your room and be away
from all this stuff
and it is because think you can go in
your room you can play games yeah
whatever
no it was you gotta you have to sit next
to him that's
what's he doing just sitting and
watching there's nothing doing nothing
you sit there and do nothing next to
somebody doing nothing is terrifying
i tell you this all the dishes always
got clean
i did i mowed the lawn i did all i yeah
you mowed the lawn
i didn't have any brothers i didn't have
any older brothers i was the uh oldest i
have a younger brother
and we're five years old get the rice
out of the car
the big pound the big i had to get the
rice get the water jug
my dad was raising me like a boy fix the
tires do the yard work
learn how to change oil what did he do
then my dad was always
watching he literally was like i'm
teaching you how to not need nobody
don't ask me don't wait uh do as i say
not as i do listen
do as i say not as i do i told you that
it was actually like parenting hack
right there because you don't have to do
[ __ ] for them anymore and they get to
learn how to do it like isaac's washing
my car
doing his own laundry taking out the
trash you're raising
you're raising good people i i can do i
can do everything that's why they used
to pop out so many kids at the farm
they needed help yeah they put them to
work as soon as they could
move yeah you needed you need and
remember survival rate was different
back then so he was just trying to make
see who can
who can make it all right you gotta take
care of us back to this so
you guys all have great ideas but none
of you nailed it it was actually
to get a cat oh that's cool that's it
oh i remember how bad i wanted a pet
that's true i'm not gonna beat her ass
for that no that's cute or even if your
son did that i mean that's cute yeah
that's awful
we're gonna go through it okay so
there's four slides here first one says
pros of getting a cat all of my fellow
siblings
though their opinions are less or less
important would love to have a cat
having a pet can lower stress levels and
make you happier
since it's a cat you don't have to take
it outside every day for walks
it would be so cute please you wouldn't
have to listen to me ask for a cat again
oh i would be in charge of cleaning up
after the cat
and the litter box and stuff it's like
two
i need a dog oh yeah yeah
oh yeah that's tight she's awesome
if we were to get a cat i could keep it
with me downstairs in my room
of course i would let it out of my room
but overall i would be in charge of it
and please seriously you promised me
a hamster five years ago but that never
happened
just let me have this it's in all caps
there's a little hammer should have gave
him the hamster
cute okay when you don't do it and you
remember remember you were supposed to
take me to disneyland and we never went
to disneyland
give me the cat yeah cause i'm gonna ask
for a dragon five years
the next slide that [ __ ] creates trauma
though come on guys
with the less than three sign overall
the less than three son overall having a
cats
would be pretty fun and cool and like i
said i would take care of it
i am aware of the duties of taking care
of a pet parentheses i've searched this
stuff for over five years i'm more than
prepared
and won't ever slack off doing those
duties
duties it would literally be the
happiest day of my life please
oh and then the last slide it's
ending thank you for watching and please
consider
that is you're getting the cat see now
that's a situation to where i don't have
something and i'm not in trouble so i'm
gonna
give you my case that's very smart
that's like you did the chores for like
a week
perfectly before you know right that's
true i just
begged every day until my parents
couldn't take it anymore
and we looked on the classifieds and
they said free dog and i was like it's
free
and you got a dog what is the one thing
you wanted that your parents never gave
you
never lego pirate ship what you wanted a
dog never got it you wanted a lego
pirate ship
yep um love damn i was about to say that
yeah
anywhere mad i want that they're present
love spinsters cat too much of that
i think i think pets because then they
got it all after i left like
that's fine my
my mom my mom got my brother's a dog
oh hell no really
i wanted a dog my whole [ __ ] life i
wanted these and now i can did you beg
enough as much as they did
oh i did not i was not that annoying i
guess i don't know
see yeah you win by being annoying i
learned that very early no you don't
because isaac tries to play that trick
and i'm like listen the more you ask the
less you're going to get it
and you guys only have one one baby one
child 12 year old yeah
see i think when you start having
multiple children is when stuff starts
going like
it's overwhelming when you have multiple
women first off my sister got everything
she got an industrial bar
piercing when she was in like high
school she was allowed to do way more
stuff than
me and then my brother just had it you
can see the comparison
comparison yeah my sister i all i wanted
were these timberland boots i only
wanted timberland boots that was it
there was those are nice i wanted the
knee-high ones that uh kelly rowland had
in that damn video
that's all i wanted was these timberland
boots and they didn't get it for me but
my sister got her industrial bar
the same like year and i was like really
she could get holes in her ear
i just want shoes and i never got them
they're like it cost less
they were just like why they were they
were just like
why i'm like but she got a bar you know
i only have these yeah i feel like i got
all the hand-me-downs
and then my little sister got like
anything she wanted because she was like
the princess
i feel like the younger the youngest by
that time they're just kind of like
they don't give off it's not a big deal
yeah like they mature too
yeah and they get tired yeah it's like
the first child
they they try to do everything properly
the second time they're like [ __ ] it
the third one they're like just tired
and then yeah yeah because i knew how to
be
like i knew how to get my way because
they were overworked like a [ __ ]
and i exploited that [ __ ] where do you
fall in the
oldest youngest i'm the youngest because
my brother's but my brother's like a
third parent because he's 12 years older
oh
[ __ ] yeah yeah if we get pregnant no
he's gonna be like 13 14 years old
yeah for me and my brother there's a
five year difference but totally like
different dynamic
like really different my sister and i
were three years apart and
it's just not the same my sister had
everything like she did she could go
she could party she'd do whatever she
really they kind of were like
we're gonna let her happy is she younger
than you she is maybe they just got
tired they're like whatever
i think they just were tired dealing
with me like there was
they put a lot into me my mom used to
cut the crust off my sandwiches like i'm
spoiled my dad
my dad used to bring me like cooked food
to school
that's really spoiled i am this one i'm
spoiled i'm spoiled in
love a lot of love a lot of attention
but i also had a [ __ ] ton of
responsibility
that's dope i had to clean everything i
had to do everything they got tired as
the
kids got popped out they're just like
let's not cut the crust anymore it's
just too much
i think what it was is that they just
knew i would do it so
that's what my dad would always say like
it doesn't matter if that was her job
if i come home and the shit's not done
that's your job to make sure that it's
done
so they kind of they put everything on
me did not yeah i'm traumatized still
sometimes trauma is good sometimes
trauma is good sometimes yeah
yeah i definitely can do more than my
sister and brother yeah sometimes
the pain is what makes you stronger and
you look back and you're like
it makes sense yeah now no wonder i'm
successful and my siblings aren't
if i got married though and like we
didn't have pets and i really wanted one
she did i'll probably make a
presentation
okay so did you guys worry about
parenting when
you got with your partner like did you
were you concerned that their parenting
styles would be different than yours and
how do you guys find a compromise
i didn't have the vision to see that far
ahead no no no you just kind of
we just kind of figured it out together
we were like 22
when we got together or something yeah
so you guys kind of like idiots just
kind of figure it out you're like oh i
guess this is better parenting if we did
this
how old was isaac when isaac was four
when he met him yeah yeah
but he he quickly turned five so he was
like i guess five yeah
yeah for me i i knew that i was just
gonna follow her program
because when we first got together like
she would take her nephews and nieces
around all the time and there's like a
big-ass group of them and just seeing
how she takes care of kids
from like three to eight to twelve i'm
like damn she really knows how to do
this thing yeah you were like cool i
trust you i'm like i'll do that
um but i know that you don't like to
beat kids so if you need kids to be beat
that's where my specialty is
you're the enforcer i feel like i'm like
the the
the mother dad another dad well like
i'll cook i'll clean i do all that stuff
and i try to be there
yeah yeah he is i'm looking for a
stay-at-home husband yeah
and you can stay at home and take care
of our kids
oh [ __ ] pick your position in this photo
like
[Applause]
yeah i'm dad we could be part-time man
we're trying
i joke about it all the because guys ask
like what type of guy are you looking
for or oh if i was rich i would get a
girl like you and i'm like first off i'm
trying to keep your ass at home
uh i don't need you doing too much i get
extremely jealous
so the public don't need it if he's too
rich
i need a balance i'm like look i love
kids don't get me wrong but i also need
a man that loves kids
more than i do you wanna but you know
like
you wanna cook you need off days i need
i think that they're
important i think that in a relationship
it shouldn't be like
the man goes to work and the woman stays
home and cleans you need a lion
because lions they chill and then take
care of the cubs
while the lioness goes out and does the
hunting line
the lion [ __ ] all the girls though yeah
he does [ __ ] first off that's how you
end up dead
i do like that that's like you end up
dead so you don't want to lie
i don't i want like lying you know what
like i said it's come on balance you
want a lion that's tired after one life
once you've done it like i want to get
somebody like retire like
[Music]
retired
[Music]
you